My name is Katarzyna Żeglicka.
I'm a feminist and queer activist
from Poland.
I'm also a performer, choreographer
and Wendo trainer -
assertiveness and self-defense
training for women and girls.
I'd define my art as the
art of resistance.
I like to say that it is activism
through dance.
A very important part of my life
with movement
was the dance study
"Resonance of Contrast".
The show was presented on a medical chair,
which was a very important decision in this performance.
I sat on it and tried to show
the experiences of women
in contact with medical institutions.
The next layer of the performance
was a film with my eyes
with nystagmus
displayed in front of the audience.
So, again, I tried to provoke people
watching me, but also myself to look
at my non-normative eyes
that are constantly in motion.
The whole performance lasts 10 minutes
and the whole study was through me
as if I was dancing
to the sound of an MRI scan.
I wanted to show how the contrast that I am,
which is in my eyes and in my gaze,
resonates with the viewer,
but also how I resonate
with Polish violent institutions.
For me, creating, moving, dancing,
it creates a sense of freedom
and independence
but also a form of opposition and resistance,
a form of shouting and anger.
I'm at a moment where I'm trying to confront
viewers with how I live
with an impairment and a non-normative body.
I try to put people who are watching me
in a slightly uncomfortable position
and confront them with what is happening
to me somehow,
with what happens to me in life.
However, I don't treat my art as therapy,
it is more a form of disagreement, resistance to
what happens to disabled women.